Swindon I Stephen Peter Taylor being the
acting returning officer at this
election do hereby give notice that the
number of votes recorded for each
candidate at this election is as follows
Andrew Headley John Bentley Green Party
858 mark Edward Dempsey Labour Party 20
1096 Stephen Frank Holden UK
Independence Party 1564 just in Paul
Tomlinson the Conservative Party
candidate twenty nine thousand four
hundred and the river birth Marvell
Webster Liberal Democrat 1962 and there
were 104 rejected ballot papers and I do
hereby declare that Justin for Thomasin
a duly elected as Member of Parliament
for North Swindon thank you and I'd like
to pay my tribute and thanks to the
returning officer the police and the
election team are fantastic
award-winning election team here in
Swindon to once again deliver such a
quick and Swift result tonight my result
tonight is a decisive result I have
secured the highest ever vote of any
candidate in the history of the Swindon
seat I am delighted to have secured
support in every single ward right
across the political spectrum my
campaign has been positive building on
my seven years as the MP for my fellow
local residents in North Swindon and I
pay tribute to my opponents for our
world's good spirited and well-fought
campaign the Conservative government has
delivered a growing economy delivering
record employment with over ten thousand
six hundred more people need work in
Swindon a staggering fall in
unemployment of 61 percent we've been
able to increase funding on our vital
public services with Robert and I
working hard to get a
percent increase in our local health
funding and extra funding for our our
schools and in Theresa May we have the
prime minister who is best place to
negotiate and deliver the brexit that
the country has spoken for now
nationally it is too too early to see
how things will pan out but I am proud
that Swindon has yet again delivered a
Conservative MP towards two reason may
once again becoming the prime minister I
want to thank everybody in Swindon I'm
extremely proud to represent my fellow
local residents and I will be as an
enthusiastic and determined as I was the
first night I was elected to champion
our brilliant tan thank you
[Applause]